[Music]
from the only movie star who's resisted
the cult of superhero movies because you
know one at a time comes a smash hit
full of real planes real sets and real
action he may have really started a war
at the end there guy takes his craft
that seriously
top gun
maverick
tom cruise returns in his iconic role as
maverick for a film about how tom i mean
maverick may be old the future is coming
and you're not in it but i mean maverick
won't go down that easy you kind of set
it for extinction maybe so sorry
but not today because tom i mean
maverick refuses to die no matter how
many dumb stunts top or mav pulls for
mission impossible or the navy or
whatever
teachers have been telling us their jobs
are hard for years but now a blockbuster
will make their complaints look
interesting watch maverick have to teach
the next generation of full-grown adults
who go by their gamer tags phoenix
hangman playback fanboy to forget going
by the book
forget playing by the rules it's
dogfight football offense and defense at
the same time and you know what just
forget thinking entirely life's easier
that way don't think just do don't think
just do don't think just do it don't
think
just do what the hell were you even
thinking you told me not to think
as he teaches his students the most
important lesson of all if you ever get
in big trouble call your boss's boss to
yell at them you get yourself in trouble
iceman makes a call
and you're back in the air for reasons
known only to the almighty and your
guardian angel
you've been called back to top gun thank
you for your service daddy
speaking of nepotism maverick will take
goose's son rooster under his wing he's
determined to follow in his father's
footsteps and entire face but first he
must let go of blaming maverick for his
father's death and maverick must make
lieutenant rooster less of a [ __ ]
increase to 500 knots negative yale hold
your speed rooster relate with 20
seconds behind and drop it come on
rooster you got him drop down and take
the shot
too late you had your chance
damn it yeah rooster is a pretty lame
call sign but it's still miles better
than bradley bradshaw bradley bradshaw
math brad brad and the rest of the gang
have just three weeks to pull off
mission extremely difficult your target
is an impact point less than three
meters wide between two mountains
assuming you avoid crashing into this
mountain you'll climb straight up into
enemy radar while losing all of your
airspeed to the point where using killer
drones seems like the more humane choice
yikes but if you want to end your movie
with the high stakes dog fight you can't
go wrong with watching pilots zoom
through a canyon trench staying low
under the enemy guns and aircraft
launching a precision guided missile
down the ventilation shaft of an enemy
doomsday weapon without the use of their
targeting system and surviving thanks to
the last second intervention of a cocky
bad boy even though all they really did
was kick off a much bigger conflict in
the next one the reveal of mig-29 was
secretly maverick's father yet
enjoy the rare legacy sequel that
actually works by weaving callbacks and
characters into the story instead of
forcing in cameos and references wait
you can do that i didn't friend no
ghosts like maverick buzzing the tower
to save the jobs of his colleagues
bringing back iceman but evolving their
relationship and the return of kelly
mcgillis no and the return of meg ryan's
photograph because ew the love interest
actually aged in the last 36 years
instead of whatever it is tom cruise
does to spit in the face of death
let's just pretend that one line about
the admiral's daughter is jennifer
connolly now penny phew that was close
almost considered my own mortality for a
sack
so strap in for the ultimate jets go
vroom spectacle
that's been called out by the woke mob
for being blatant military propaganda
but they are just butthurt because
america is number one we do nothing
wrong and we have no problems whatsoever
now where's the recruiting booth i want
to play some topless beach football
uss
uss usms
starring
captain america the sprinter soldier my
name is bradley bradshaw you kill my
father prepare to fly hulk smashed
d
ck
pullman
phoenix flight ace aviator
lawrence of arabia
sad martign
depression is caused by the souls of
dead aliens admiral
dick seaman
when they open the movie with danger
zone nice when they don't play take my
breath away damn and g4 sing out a big
dumb
[Music]
hotshots part crews
people wasted all this time arguing over
what country they bombed when the real
enemy was right in front of us the whole
time birds
bird strike first strike
tom cruise has been in movies since 1981
and he's put up some serious numbers on
screen we watched every film he's ever
made to bring you his total career
running stats hang time and every one of
his characters actual height click the
link in the description or the thumbnail
on the right to watch a brand new
episode of by the numbers tom cruise
uh-oh snapping back to reality oops
there goes gravity mom's spaghetti
it's my money and i need it now
wonder boy what is the secret of your
power
i made a milkshake and all the boys
showed up in my yard